Okay. So that's how a single checkbox works
but, rarely do you see a single checkbox by itself.
Usually you see them in a group.
So let's add a few more here.
So I've added two more checkboxes--
type="checkbox"--
and I've made their names be "r" and "s".
So now we have "q", "r", and "s".
And then I also added a line break so it can
have a little separation from our Submit button.
Let's see how this looks in our browser.
Okay. If I Reload this page in our browser,
now we see--we have 3 checkboxes
and they can be toggled on and off,
as you do with checkboxes.
Now what I'd like you to do is
tell me what happens when I check
these first 2 checkboxes and I hit Submit.
So when we select the first two checkboxes and click Submit,
what does the "query" section of the URL look like?
Remember, the query section--that's the name
for the portion of the URL, after the question mark.